depuis l'invasion de l'ukraine la
machine de propagande russe tourne à
plein régime ce mercredi matin rossiya
24 une chaîne d'information géré par
l'état de diffuser cette vidéo le
commentateur accuse l'ukraine d'être un
état terroriste et de préparer une
attaque nucléaire sur son propre sol
c'est un groupe de saboteurs ukrainien
qui a attaqué la centrale nucléaire de
zappos liccia ils ont même provoqué un
incendie les combattants de la gare
nationales russes les ont repoussés ça
paraît incroyable mais dans les hautes
instances des services secret et des
forces armées de l'ukraine il y a des
gens prêt à perpétrer des provocations
nucléaires d'après le ministère russe de
la défense de telles tentatives pourrait
se reproduire le but est clair mettre ça
sur le dos de la fédération de russie
le même message et matraqué sans relâche
le cren serait dirigée par de dangereux
néonazis et la russie interviendrait
pour libérer le pays une thèse relayé
par ce spécialiste des questions de
défense chez l'une des plus grandes
agences de presse du pays
un autre danger n'est pas à exclure une
négligence criminelle des dirigeants
ukrainiens dans les conditions d'un état
qui s'effondre et perd le contrôle les
experts estiment que la probabilité
d'une catastrophes technogènes augmente
surtout quand tout cela s'accompagne
d'une idéologie de folie d'une
russophobie et d'année au nazisme
pour comprendre ce phénomène d'emprise
sur les esprits des russes nous avons
interrogé les goudkov sociologue dans un
institut indépendant parce que la
propagande est un phénomène assez
complexe elle se construit toujours en
deux parties et à la partie négative qui
martèle l'image de l'ennemi avec tout ce
discours de menaces à la sécurité
nationale de discrédit des valeurs
russes etc et puis il ya toujours le
discours positif si nous la russie le
pouvoir russe poutine ne faisons que le
bien nous défendons les honnêtes gens il
lui tond contre le nazisme chai
d'après une récente étude de cet
institut vladimir poutine jouir est
actuellement d'une cote de popularité de
71%